okay I told you yesterday that we had a
four thousand dollar matching challenge
in our crowdfunding campaign we have a
target of sixty thousand dollars you can
read more about the campaign at david
pakman.com slash donate you will be able
to donate up until midnight on Donald
Trump's inauguration day what a day that
will be i predict particularly high
pharmaceutical and sedative usage that
day nationwide over the next few days up
until midnight in fact on friday every
dollar you donate will be matched dollar
for dollar by an anonymous a longtime
supporter of the show you go to david
pakman.com slash donate you donate 10
bucks that actually gets us twenty bucks
you donate a hundred bucks that gets is
200 every dollar up to the next four
thousand dollars raised will be matched
dollar for dollar please don't make me
turn away free money that is available
you can donate their a couple of really
popular perks that are being snatched up
from the campaign are the two custom
exclusive david pakman show t-shirts the
first one of course is the hatred mail t
shirt this shirt is only available
through the david pakman show fundraiser
at david pakman.com slash donate also
the established in 2005 david pakman
show t-shirt again only available
through the david pakman show fundraiser
even if you can only donate a few
dollars i always say donate anyway
especially now that your few dollars
will be doubled into two times the few
dollars you can donate through midnight
friday please please please we've got to
do this we have a dire situation up
coming over the next four years we must
be prepared independent progressive
media must be supported and you can do
that at david pakman.com slash donate